ça arriverait si on était d'accord tous
les deux en même temps on n'est jamais
que vous êtes raisonnable autrui est ce
que vous pensez justement des gens âgés
qui continuent à avoir des relations
amoureuses et sexuelles entre ça paraît
normal
moi je crois que c'est pas possible
arrivé à un certain âge parce que moi je
trouve qu'on n'est pas un couple anormal
et bien cette chose là c'est secondaire
vous êtes encore un peu amoureuse de lui
et sentimentalement oui et lui pas mal
mais un pack salle sentiments et
l'action ça fait du thé ce qu'on fait
pour répondre aux demandes sept
partenaires ballon chambre hp après on
fait ce qu'on peut
et les gens qui trouve ça un peu un peu
indécent qu'on n'aille pas au cul faut
être con vous ça fait partie de vos
préoccupations encore un petit peu
ouais ouais je pomme enterrés vivants
c'est pas parce qu'on a 77 ans rue il
faut en profiter
un bain c'est à dire le désirent on
essaye de le voir mais on cherche un peu
quand même
on est obligé de le chercher mais quand
il arrive alors là ça fait mal on a des
fantasmes des rêves érotiques ça vous
arrive vous ne rêvez vous oui c'est
arrivé ça oui mais sur des vieux
souvenirs
enfin les souvenirs qui reviennent quand
même et c'est ça qui vous donne un peu
d'ardeur
vous allez penser peut-être un jour
n'aurait plus de relation en relation
sexuelle ben oui quand même on y pense
un peu à ça parce qu'il n'y a pas de
problème quand on commence par exemple
avec un conte les plus bas
on trouve plus rien si l'on veut dire ça
va être triste
là je pense je voudrais que c'est normal
que les personnes âgées des relations
amoureuses naturellement c'est normal
c'est plus que normal c'est naturel
ça peut aller jusqu'où ces relations se
peut aller jusqu'à la terminaison 1
je ne crois qu'il faut chercher l'enfant
pour la trouver c'est à dire faut
attendre jusqu'à l'extinction des forces
tant qu'on peut le faire allons-y qu'est
ce que vous en pensez vous madame
moi je suis d'accord pour une femme de
75 ans sur le plan sexuel commencer par
rapport au passé
bon je trouve qu'il n'ya pas tellement
de changements
c'est moins bien c'est aussi bien
qu'avant oh oui je suis bien
vous êtes exigeante avec vos partenaires
oui vos amis votre entourage c'est que
vous avez une manie berthet sexuelle que
vous vivez toujours oui mondial sports
il ya pas de raison je pensais qu'on a
c'est bien je ne suis pas j'irai pas
plainte et les fesses d'une femme dans
le métro non ça ne plaît pas jeudi il
est bien chez mon jeu qui tombe molik le
tonnerre mais c'est tout voilà c'est pas
parce qu'on vieillit qu'on n'a plus de
désir
moi j'ai mis un bon casse croûte
c'est aussi bien qu'avant ah oui
pourquoi pas c'est peut-être moins
souvent pour vous la vrai c'est vrai ce
qu'elle dit c'est moi souvent mais c'est
toujours bien et ça vous arrive de rêver
à sa camaro idée fois ces tags réalisés
oui c'est pas désagréable
oui mais qu'est ce qui fait que ce rêve
c'est toujours bref c'est ce que vous
vous sentez plus hardis aujourd'hui vous
car attend allons quand même pas ma faim
toutes les occasions que je peux avoir
moi j'ai loupé à il faut profiter encore
des jeunes
les amoureux qui se bécotent sur les
bancs publics
bancs publics bancs publics en foutant
pas mal du regard oblique des passants
honnêtes les amis
[Musique]